la preocupación de la comunidad
internacional aumenta en torno a la
crisis en Sudán este miércoles los
líderes de Naciones Unidas remarcaron la
necesidad de tener garantías para los
combaches humanitarios en el país el
jefe de ayuda de la organización Martin
griffith Busca lograr reuniones cara a
cara con Los líderes de las facciones en
conflicto para pedir garantías
necesitamos acceso necesitamos
transporte aéreo necesitamos suministros
que no sean saqueados el programa
mundial de alimentos me ha informado hoy
que seis camiones suyos que iban a
darfur fueron saqueados en ruta a pesar
de las garantías de seguridad se trata
de un entorno volátil por lo que
necesitamos esos compromisos que es una
de mis obligaciones en esta visita a
sudan y a la región
antes del conflicto un tercio de la
población de Sudán ya dependía de la
ayuda humanitaria extranjera Incluso el
reciente informe publicado por la
organización para la agricultura y la
alimentación pone Sudán como uno de los
10 países más afectados por la crisis
alimentaria
hay que proteger a los civiles las
infraestructuras civiles y respetar a
los trabajadores y bienes humanitarios
algún llamamiento a la comunidad
internacional para que apoyen el pueblo
sudanés en su búsqueda de paz y Retorno
a la transición democrática
los choques entre el ejército y para
dejan ya más de 100.000 refugiados en
países vecinos y más de 330.000
desplazados internos